pierre laurin journaliste écrivain
spécialiste de la russie
bonjour alors un merci d'être en direct
avec nous alors on l'a entendu le
président russe vladimir poutine une
intervention au forum de davos la
dernière sa dernière intervention ce
temps en tant que chef du gouvernement
en 2009 cette année c'est une
participation qui est quand même
particulière dans le contexte que de
crises sanitaires que l'on connaît oui
effectivement d'abord bonjour je crois
que si vladimir poutine tenu à parler
dans le cadre de ce forum virtuel vous
c'est parce que la situation
internationale exige de la russie qui
est une des principales puissances
de la planète de proposer une certaine
vision de la praye il est très clair
qu'il va y avoir un monde d'après est ce
que la lumière poutine tenais à dire
c'est que ce monde d'après ne doit pas
être n'importe quoi qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de règles à respecter
dans le domaine essentiellement
économique et social et que son message
principal c'est bien entendu ne pas
laisser de côté des millions et des
millions d'habitants de la planète
alors il a eu des phrases que l'on a
retenu notamment celles ci le monde ne
peut plus avancer en laissant les plus
pauvres de côté il a lancé un appel
aussi à aider justement les pays les
plus défavorisés notamment en matière de
lutte contre le corona virus faisant
aussi référence au continent africain
oui effectivement je crois que
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est la lutte
contre le coronavirus et comment on va
sortir de cette crise sanitaire mondiale
et la russie a apporté un élément de
solution avec son vaccin sopic v qui est
le premier vaccin avoir été enregistrés
dans la planète et qui aujourd'hui est
administrée non seulement en russie mais
dans un certain nombre d'autres pays
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
vaccination en russie a commencé au mcs
décembre que les personnes les plus
sensibles à la maladie ont été vaccinées
que depuis quelques quelques jours la
vaccination a été élargie c'est une
action vaccination de masse élargi à la
totalité de la population et pas
seulement aux personnes âgées aux
personnes à risque et autres comme cela
se pratique dans la plupart des pays
occidentaux
de ce point de vue là des maires poutine
a expliqué entre guillemets sans le dire
vraiment que il fallait un effort commun
et que l'ostracisme de nombreux pays à
l'égard du spoutnik v devait cesser
parce que justement ce qui est
intéressant de ce vaccin ce qui les
fabriquent et une grande quantité qu'il
est disponible pour la plupart des pays
du monde et qu' il est absurde de le
laisser de côté d'ailleurs il ya
quelques jours la chancelière allemande
angela merkel à initier un rapprochement
en direction de la russie ayant des sur
le thème du vaccin spots xv et qui
devrait être homologué par les agences
de santé européennes
bien entendu après l'étude du dossier
mais jusqu'à présent jusqu'à cette prise
de parole d'angela merkel
les agences de santé européennes
n'envisageait même pas d'étudier le
dossier que pouvaient présenter les
russes ce que l'on comprend finalement
faisait allusion à un gala merkel on a
entendu à le président russe et il faut
mettre fin à une forme de guerre
des vaccins qui se joue actuellement
voir les pays occidentaux et le vaccin
spoutnik weill qui est produit est
notamment utilisé dans les pays du sud
en grande majorité
oui oui de toute manière je crois que là
maintenant on entre dans une situation
qui est vraiment creed dans la mesure où
on se rend compte que vague après vague
mutants mi temps on est parti pour
des années peut en tout cas des mois de
cette situation où
on aussi entre les confinements entre
les mesures strictes les mesures un peu
moins stricte où personne ne comprend
plus rien et sans une volonté commune de
l'ensemble des pays qui sont en mesure
de produire deux vaccins de collaborer
pour mettre des vaccins à la disposition
de leur population d'abord mais
également des pays qui n'ont pas les
capacités pharmaceutique ou le faire
sans cela il est vraisemblable qu'on
règle on restera dans cette situation
très particulière et que les résultats
les résultantes dans le domaine social
dans le domaine économique et même dans
le domaine politique ce qu'a souligné le
président poutine seront catastrophiques
le président russe qui a évoqué les
défis socioéconomiques il a déclaré
leire des tentatives de créer un monde
unipolaire est révolu que faut-il
comprendre
je crois qu'il tire les enseignements de
la situation actuelle où on voit que
toutes les tentatives qui ont été faits
au cours des cinquante dernières années
même un peu avant pour créer une
stabilité géostratégique
d'abord entre les états unis et l'union
soviétique
mais ensuite entre les différents pays
qui c'était
occupée qui avait occupé plutôt la scène
politique après l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique tout cela a été mise
à bas par une politique de destruction
des instruments internationaux de
maintien de l' équilibre et qui s'est
avéré complètement irrationnel là
aujourd'hui on voit que toutes les
tentatives qui ont été faites pour
essayer de ramener par les occidentaux
j'entends ramener la démocratie dans les
pays arabes m havas certains dictateurs
attention pas tout seulement ce qui
était du mauvais côté de la barrière
tout ça ça n'a mené à rien les printemps
arabes sont une catastrophe
à l'exception peut-être de la tunisie et
encore on est dans une situation où
effectivement il a conduite de certains
pays peut dégénérer d'une certaine
manière en conflit ouvert en
affrontement etc et on est finalement
dans la mauvaise position pour continuer
cette politique on voit très bien
quelles sont ses limites donc pas
plupart des pays qui ne sont ni
appartiennent pas au camp occidental
estime que ça suffit il ya d'autres
manières de mener une politique globale
de revenir aux institutions
traditionnelles de respecter les traités
ce que les états unis n'ont pas fait
puisqu'ils se sont retirés
successivement d'un ensemble de traiter
qui garantissait une certaine stabilité
est maintenant si le président byden
accepte alors que les démocrates étaient
tout à fait opposés à cela accepte de
revenir de proroger le traité new star
sur les armements stratégiques entre les
etats-unis et la russie c'est parce
qu'effectivement on se rend compte que
s'il n'y a plus rien plus aucun
instrument international garantissant
une certaine
et une certaine stabilité est bien
n'importe quoi que ce produit est en
tout cas la première conséquence directe
ce serait une relance une relance de la
course aux armements puisque ce qui
s'est passé dans les années 60 pourrait
se reproduire a pu alors justement hier
vladimir poutine s'est entretenu avec
son homologue américain joe biden à
propos justement du traité new start qui
doit expirer le 5 février ils se sont
entendus sur le prolongement de ce
traité et la douma a ratifié la décision
de proroger donc le traité sur les
arsenaux nucléaires signé en 2010
ça c'est un signe positif
c'est un signe positif effectivement
l'impasse l'intégrer dans les relations
entre les etats-unis et la russie et
plus exactement entre le monde
occidental et là aussi c'est un pass
venait de la volonté pratiquement
exclusive des états unis de se libérer
de toutes les contraintes
le café était imposé au fil du temps à
les traiter le signé avec l'union
soviétique puis avec la russie pour
limiter les arguments stratégique pour
maintenir un certain équilibre mais
également au cours des dernières années
à la volonté des démocrates américains
de diaboliser leurs adversaires donald
prin en prétendant que il avait partie
liée avec la russie ce qui les enquêtes
menées aux états unis par différents
organismes officiels ont montré que ce
n'était pas vrai mais n'empêche le
cheval de bataille des démocrates
c'était comme et la russie veulent des
père l'amène or
et ça continue mais maintenant puisque
hillary clinton dernièrement a prétendu
que les émeutes au capitole était
téléguidé par la russie ce qui est assez
absurde là je crois que madame clinton
devient un tout petit peu ou même tout à
fait maniaque
maintenant il n'y a plus d'adversaires
preuve maintenant pour joe biden il faut
qu'ils règlent les problèmes réels à les
problèmes fantasme est donc un
rapprochement avec la russie est
inévitable parce que c'est allé trop
loin
il faut revenir en arrière il faut
pouvoir accepter de négocier dans très
de s'asseoir à une table de négociation
ce qui était impossible jusqu'à présent
il faut négocier ce traité le problème
la prolongation du traité ue sera
peut-être en incluant d'autres pays
mais tout ça ça se il faut il faut
parler ça se négocie et ça ne se règle
pas à l'exclusive non vous êtes les
méchants nous semblait gentil on ne
parlera pas bon ça ne marche pas ça ne
peut plus marcher maintenant ce qu'il
faut c'est effectivement négocié mais je
crois que là ce que cette prorogation du
traité ue stat est un début mais cela
passe également à un certain n'ont pas
l'arrêt parce qu' il est impossible
d'arrêter la diabolisation de la russie
telles que les pays occidentaux la mène
depuis maintenant six ou sept ans né au
moins freiner ce mouvement qui qui tient
à qui était atteint des niveaux
absolument invraisemblable lorsque le
journal le monde dans un éditorial en
juin anglais la merkel d'arrêter les
travaux sur le gazoduc north stream 2 en
disant que la russie n'est pas
fréquentable
je voudrais bien que toutes les
personnes qui ont collaboré à la
rédaction de cet éditorial abandonnent
leurs téléphones chinois leur ordinateur
chinois leurs vêtements chinois parce
que en chine les droits de l'homme et
bien écoutez moins ça n'a aucun rapport
avec ce qui se passe en russie
donc on ne peut pas continuer à tout
miser sur une politique antirusse qui ne
mènent nulle part la russie est un
partenaire
la russie nous fournit d'une manière
impeccable le gaz dont nous avons besoin
la russie participe à toutes les
initiatives de stabilité sur la planète
dans les organisations internationales
notamment et la russie c'est un
formidable débouchés pour les industries
européennes pour l'économie mais center
mais si beaucoup à cette longue analyse
on va poursuivre tout de suite merci je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
écrivain spécialiste de la russie ont
pour